hello everybody walk into another bar
graphics video just before we jump into
it a quick message from our sponsor now
you might have heard of the little
YouTube channel cinemasins it's not
really little at all it's got I mean 8
million subscribers or something crazy
like that well the co-founder and the
narrator of that channel Jeremy Scott he
wrote a book in fact he actually wrote
two books this one a while ago this one
strings coming out real soon on the 24th
of September you could pre-order it now
this one the original one you can
already get this wherever you get your
books or just go to cinema since com
forward such books to find the links to
all of those places these books follow a
chap called Philip who basically attends
a superhero school he's a superhero if
you like like superheroes and stuff and
Disney and whatnot then you're probably
going to like this stuff the plot twist
is that superheroes can be disabled too
indeed Philip is blind
he's also got telekinesis so you know
pros and cons basically these books
they're a really nice take on the
superhero genre offering just something
a little bit different a little bit
inspiring and here you are you clicked
on a video about Disney so I don't think
it's too much of a stretch do you think
that you will like these books like I
say you can all the first book right now
you can get this one on the 24th or
pre-order it just go to cinemasins comm
forward slash book and thanks to them
for the sponsorship and let's get into
it so today's highly recognizable
protagonist was hailed as a genius of
entertainment a wizard of animation a
pioneer of Technology and theme parks
the influence of Walt Disney on today's
popular culture and collective
imagination it cannot be understated you
can love him you can hate him or you can
love to hate him but you simply cannot
ignore his work Walt Disney once
famously said that laughter is America's
greatest export but well it's not it's
actually travel and transportation with
236 billion dollars in sales in 2017 but
sale of intellectual property including
TV and movies amounts to 49 billion
dollars which is still big indeed it's
twice the GDP of Cyprus so if by
laughter we mean entertainment then yeah
American entertainment is one of the
country's most important exports and
these days a good chunk of that
intellectual property is owned by Walt
Disney Studios Pixar Wayne Avista
Miramax plus the Marvel and Star Wars
franchises are some of the largest and
most visible entertainment companies
owned by the house of mouse Disney's
legacy it can capture the imagination of
every girl or boy from early childhood
all the way through adulthood and to
think it all started with the doodle of
a mouse sketched during a depressing
train ride home but well we're getting
ahead of ourselves Walter Elias Disney
later known as uncle Walter was born on
December the 5th 1901 in Chicago
Illinois
his parents flora and Eliza were farmers
and occasional entrepreneurs of Canadian
origin what was the youngest of five
siblings the others being Ruth Roy
Raymond and Herbert his much older
brothers would prove a source of
stability and inspiration later in life
at the age of seven waltz and the
Disney's they moved council city where
he spent most of his childhood this was
an unhappy period of his life though the
last senior had a hard time making a
living switching from farming to
distributing newspapers in each of these
activities Walt's and his siblings were
drafted to work hard and contribute to
the family's welfare Elias visit tough
work master and did not approve of all
trying to carve out time to do homework
or even a 10:00 school you can probably
imagine how a liar stick to his son's
budding talent for drawing he considered
it a complete waste of time and would
not spend a cent on something as futile
as art supplies Walter he was reduced to
drawing his first sketches on toilet
paper Walt's harsh relationship with his
father was mitigated by Walt's close
relationship with his big brothers
especially Roy ins Herbert who were an
early source of encouragement for him
unfortunately Roy Raymond's and
Herbert's they moved out of the family
home eventually leaving behind the much
younger Walt in 1917 the u.s. joined the
on haunt in World War one alongside many
other patriotic American boys Walt
longed to do his part by donning uniform
to serve in France he may have also had
the added motivation to leave his home
behind considering the fact that he
faked his age joined the army at 16 Walt
was likely trying to escape from his
home life unfortunately he
was rejected for being too short Walter
had a plan B though he successfully
applied to join the American Red Cross
while training as an ambulance driver
what developed his artistic skills and
he became quite popular for decorating
the ambulances with cartoons and
caricatures of fellow paramedics one of
his fellow trainees by the way that was
Ray Kroc later the legendary CEO of
McDonald's Walt's appetite for action it
remains unfulfilled the war was over
before he was even deployed overseas but
when he returned home he had good reason
to rejoice he had found out that he had
won a scholarship to attend the Kansas
City Art Institute after years owing to
drawn toilet paper and ambulances the
poor guy did deserve a break and at last
he got his proper art supplies while
attending the Art Institute Walt
developed a fascination for the growing
genre of animation animated shorts were
commonly used at the time in movie
theaters as a crowd-pleaser before the
main feature that they were crudely made
and the soundtrack was irrelevant and
some of them were pretty darn creepy
Walt saw an opportunity to fill a
potential gap in the market with
products of good quality with a friend
from the Art Institute
I works Walt sent up his first animation
company it was a bold move considering
that the two were 19 and had little to
no capital to start with Walt and herb
developed a p-- series of short animated
movies for the Newman chain of cinemas
entitled Newman's laugh-o-grams
the company it was short-lived running
from 1920 to 1923 but its coatings were
a hit with audiences Walt experimented
with some of the themes that would later
become a staple of his production
anthropomorphised animals innovative
takes on classic fairy tales a keen eye
for popular music jazz of the time and
slapstick humor as talented animators as
Walt and I may have been as businessman
they were kinda rubbish the production
costs of their shorts were too high and
they signed unfair distribution deals
they thought they'd hit the jackpot when
a distributor company called pictorial
clubs of Tennessee promised $11,100 for
six cartoons that's 142,000 in today's
money but pictorial never paid in the
laugh-o-gram company that soon when
interesting aside here if today some
lava grams are still intact and
available it's thanks to those pictorial
Club scoundrels they kept these six
cartoons in their vaults and reissued
them when Disney had become a household
name
the fellow animator and other employees
of Walt's startup well they're about to
call it quits but Wells had
idea with great potential how about
mixing a live-action with animation
bolts pitch was to film a series of
short starring actress Virginia Davis
with an innovative technique mixing a
live-action protagonist with animated
characters and settings Walter nut moved
to California to start work on this new
series entitled the Alice comedies their
early work attracted the attention of
new york-based distributor Margaret J
Winkler Disney's work was again plagued
by too high production costs which made
the first Alice comedies unprofitable on
Winkler's insistence Walton AB were
forced to increase their rate of
production while lowering the animators
salaries by this time big brother Roy
Disney adjoined the company and he
seemed to have a much better business
since than Walt he would remain his
business partner and trusted advisor for
the rest of his life it was perhaps on
Roy's advice that Walter nub decided to
hire an entirely female crew of
colorists traditional animation required
for each frame of a cartoon to be
colored by hands and that's 24 frames
per second of footage so it's a
meticulous repetitive time-consuming job
requiring large numbers of skilled
professionals at that time women's wages
were much lower than men's which meant
savings for the Disney brothers one of
the colorists was a young women from
Idaho called Lillian at the end of a
long day's work Walt would routinely
drive her him a group of his employees
whatever the roots he would always make
sure that the last person to be dropped
off was Lillian so that he could spend
more time alone with her Lillian
probably got for him since the two
started dating and this led to a short
engagement and to their wedding in July
of 1925 by 1927 American audiences had
grown weary of the Alice comedies shorts
and Walt wanted to diversify his
production he started working on a new
character Oswald the Lucky Rabbit this
series was successful and Walt
considered rescinding his contract with
Margaret Winkler to chance distribution
on his own but in 1928 Walt discovered
that Margaret and her husband Charles
Mintz later
raph Universal Pictures were masters of
the fine prints at the bottom of
contract during a business meeting in
New York he learns that as part of the
deal with Winkler every intellectual
property developed within the terms of
the contract would be legally owned by
Winkler and Mintz unbeknownst to him the
New York power couple had another nasty
trick in reserve their pushy demands and
deadlines for the Alice films
alienated Disney's animators most of
them had vented their frustration
against Walt rather than Winkler so when
they avenged
quit the company they were hired on mass
by Universal only Iwerks would remain by
Walt's side while riding the train back
to California from New York a depressed
Walt Disney but pencil to paper to
soothe his sadness and frustration
little did he know that doodle would
change his life and have a huge impact
on the life of millions of children the
character that he sketched that day was
the immortal Mortimer mouse so now you
might be asking well Mortimer who well
that character was Mickey Mouse but
Walt's initial choice of name was
Mortimer luckily Lillian talked into his
senses and advised that he changed the
name to Mickey if you are Vince these
sort of things the name Mortimer is of
old French origin means dead see not
exactly the chariot of names for a
talking Mouse Walt's company was now
called Walt Disney cartoons a skeleton
crew which included only him and our
bond drawing in animation duties with
Roy supervising the business and his
wife and Edna coloring and inking with
Lillian the gang soon delivered three
Mickey Mouse cartoons the first who did
not sell for the third one Walt had the
intuition to add a recent cinematic
innovation a synchronized soundtrack
which included a catchy whistling tune
this was Steamboat Willie
it opens on November the 18th 1928 and
it was an immediate success for Walt
Disney cartoons finally the big break
had arrived and the company would
produce a string of hit animated shorts
in 1929 they created the cartoon series
Silly Symphonies an 1832 episode flowers
and trees was the first cartoon to be
produced in color and to win an Oscar
the follow up the Three Little Pigs of
1933 was so popular that it got Top
Billing above the feature films that did
accompanied while working on the Silly
Symphonies Walton Lillian were trying to
conceive a child
unfortunately Lillian suffered several
miscarriages which caused Walt's you
experience and nervous breakdown
eventually a baby girl arrived in 1933
Diane the Disney's decided to adopt
another girl Sharon in 1936 the success
of his cartoons and a growing family in
bold and Walt who now started to think a
bit bigger
why should cartoons be developed only in
the short form ask why not produce a
full-length animated film
[Music]
in 1934 Walt started working on that
very idea a cartoon that ran for the
length of a feature film as he had done
previously
Walt sought inspiration from a classic
fairy tale Snow White
by the Brothers Grimm nobody in
Hollywood believed in walls among the
studio Lots film executives sneered at
the project calling it Disney's folly
the production was not easy going over
time and over budget but when Snow White
and the Seven Dwarves opened on December
the 21st 1937 it won immediately the
hearts and minds of both audiences and
critics including subsequent releases
and adjusting for inflation Snow White
is the tenth highest-grossing movie of
all time at the 1938 Academy Awards the
film was nominated for Best soundtrack
and received a special award for
significant screen innovation in the
shape of one normal-sized Oscar and
seven little statuettes Walt Disney
Studios continued working on shorts but
the main production focus was firmly on
feature-length cartoons Walt's next two
projects were incredibly ambitious he
released Pinocchio and Fantasia both in
1940 Pinocchio was a relative success
not as astounding as Snow White but well
Fantasia
it tanked if you haven't seen this movie
it is absolutely worth a watch but 1940
audiences they did not agree and for the
next production
Dumbo Walt had to tighten the belt and
reduce costs to a minimum
Dumbo's artwork and animation a visibly
cruder than the three previous movies
the running time is also quite short but
the film it was highly profitable this
relative reduction in quality may have
also been a consequence of a studio
animators strike events which deeply
angered and worried Disney a 2006
biography of Walt Disney by Neil gobbler
sheds some light on Walt's relationship
with his employees trade unions and
communism to put it simply Walt Disney
was a tough boss to work for it is no
surprise that his employees wanted to
organize themselves into a union but he
considered industrial action as a
dangerous expression of communist
tendencies how are this for an example
when Walt sent 35 is brother Roy
encouraged employees to throw the boss a
surprise birthday party two of the
animators thought it would be a fun idea
to create a short cartoon out of Mickey
and Minnie Mouse going at it when Walt
saw the animation at the party he
laughed hard and asked you've made the
film the two animators stabbed south
expect
pat on the back or a handshake and then
he fired them on the spot
in general Walt could be controlling and
he asked a lot from his employees he
often dressed them down if they did not
deliver even Roy was not spared the
business brains behind Walt Disney
Studios was frequently scolded when he
ventured an opinion and an artistic
choice of his employees animators and
cartoonists whether one subjects do the
longest hours and the most grueling work
conditions taking a break was luxurious
Walt would often appear suddenly in the
drawing rooms to check on that work
luckily for the employees what was a
heavy smoker with time he developed a
persistent cough that announced his
arrival by just a few seconds when his
cartoonist tried to form a union all
reacted by hiring armed guards firing
organizers and cutting wages and when a
major strike rolled around in 1941 well
he was really asking for it on July the
2nd 1941 Disney published an advert in
Variety accusing the strike leaders of
communists to cachi tation this concern
about communist infiltration zin
Hollywood led into drawing the motion
picture Alliance for the preservation of
American ideals or the mpa founded in
february of 1944 the NBA was an
organization composed of high-profile
showbiz personalities with the purpose
of defending Hollywood's and America as
a whole against communism and fascism
the NBA was active until 1975 and
notable members included John Wayne
Ronald Reagan and Ginger Rogers just to
name a few the NBA volunteered to
testify in front of the House Committee
on unamerican activities the committee
was created in 1938 to investigate
alleged disloyalty and subversive
activities on the part of private
citizens public employees and
organizations suspected of having
communist ties Walt also participated in
the hearings of the committee accusing
several leaders of the animators
strikers communist agitators his
testimony earns him the gratitude and
friendship of legendary FBI director J
Edgar Hoover whose life story web short
to tell her sooner or later Hoover and
Disney they developed a strange artistic
partnership in the following years J
Edgar allowed Walt Disney Studios to
film some of their live-action movies at
the FBI headquarters in Washington Walt
on the other hand agreed to submit some
of his scripts to Hoover for an early
revision to ensure that the FBI was
depicted correctly but apparently Hoover
did not make any changes to the classic
animated films in addition to these
exchanges of favors Hoover and Disney
appointed as a special agent in charge
of contact in 1954
in other words they trusted Informer and
collaborator of the FBI and his for a
fun fact decades after Walt Disney's
death his company would pay homage to
the FBI chief with a minor character J
gander hooter from the TV series
darkwing duck in the 1950s Walt Disney
eventually distanced himself from the
MPA thus he lost interest in their
ideals and the paranoid approach to
enter communism Walt's association with
the MPA is the source of the rumor that
he was anti-semitic but biographer Neal
gobbler otherwise a harsh critic of
Disney's dismisses this claim is
unsubstantiated Walt regularly hired or
had business with Jewish employees and
colleagues in 1955 he was even appointed
Man of the Year by the B'nai B'rith
International a Jewish cultural
organization this is not the only
persistent unfounded rumor on walls but
we've got a bit more on that later
[Music]
in the 1950s and 1960s Walt Disney
Studios produced a series and animated
masterpieces that one well-deserved
popular success let's list them quickly
because I know if I miss one I'm gonna
get some backlash Cinderella 1950 Alice
in Wonderland 1951 Peter Pan 1953 lady
in the trap 1955 Sleeping Beauty 1959
hundred and one Dalmatians 1961 Mary
Poppins from 1964 everybody has a
favorite from one of these films Mary
Poppins successfully merged live-action
and animation in color before that
Disney Studios had ventured into purely
live-action films the first one being
Treasure Island in 1950 Disney was also
one of the first Hollywood producers to
invest in TV the first of his series on
the small screen was the magical world
of Disney which actually can be
considered an early example of content
marketing to promote a good or service
so what was Disney promoting well I was
his next big dream the one that would
take most of his energy and attention
for the last decade of his life it was a
massive and innovative theme park in
Southern California
of course that's Disneyland the park was
developed in the town of Anaheim after
demographics experts convinced Walt that
it would become a major population
center within the next ten years time
would prove that they were absolutely
right when the local population and park
visitors sought Disneyland opens on July
the 17th 1955 and its first day was a
disaster 30,000 people turned up instead
of the projected 15,000 meaning
restaurants were soon out of food and
drink a plumber strike also forced Walt
to choose to either have flushing
toilets or working drinking fountains he
went with the toilets further one of the
attractions were so overgrown with weeds
that Disney ordered to place placards
around with Latin names on them he was
essentially disguising the shrubbery as
an arboretum
of course everything improved with time
and Disney lands became one of the most
visited and successful theme parks in
the world when looking a visitor Staats
Disney realized that only a small
fraction came from the west coast that's
when he got the idea of building a
sister park in Florida Disney World
developed around the prototype of
futuristic perfect city called Epcot but
Walt Disney would not live to see his
new dream come true for most of his
adult life he had been smoking three
packs of unfiltered cigarettes every
single day his daughter Diane tried and
failed to convince him to cut back they
reached a compromise
he would at least smoke three packs of
filtered cigarettes bus it just removed
the filters behind Diane's back
inevitably in 1966 Walt was diagnosed
with lung cancer he underwent surgery
but due to post-operative complications
altered a heart attack and died on
December the 15th 1966 at the age of 65
contrary to popular and persistent
rumors his body was not cryogenically
preserved and/or hidden in a vault under
Disneyland Walt was simply cremated and
his ashes were interned at Forest Lawn
Cemetery in Los Angeles California so I
hope you'll forgive me for stating the
obvious but Walt Disney was and still is
a controversial figure as is normal for
somebody whose influence on the
surrounding world and society is larger
than life a personality like Disney will
never be free from exaggeration slander
and rumors or the opposite risk is to
portray him exclusively in a saintly
light for sure Walt Disney was not the
fairest of business leaders not the most
balanced of workplace bosses not the
most level-headed when confronted with
different political ideas but it's also
true that he did deliver a lasting
impact on society culture and children
through his innovative work as Walt once
said I'd rather entertain and hope that
people learn than teach and hope that
people are entertained so I really hope
you found that video interesting if you
did please do hit that thumbs up button
below and don't forget to subscribe also
remember you can grab this book at
cinemasins com forward slash book you
can pre-order it right now it's released
on the 24th of September so if it's
after the 24th of September and you're
watching this well great you can grab it
now
but until then pre-order at cinemasins
com forward slash book and I'll see you
next time
[Music]